المناورات الامريكيه الفلبينيه تغضب الصين
الاطباء يلحقون بركب الاضرابات في
بريطانيا موظف بنك يقتل خمسه من زملائه في
امريكا
هذه الاخبار وغيرها ننقلها لكم من قناه
العربيه فاهلا بكم
البدايه من جنوب شرق اسيا في باب مشاركه
نحو 18 الف جنديا بدات الولايات المتحده
والفلبين مناورات عسكريه تعد الاكبر
بالنسبه لهذا البلد الاسيوي وتشمل اطلاق
نار بالذخيره الحيه لاول مره في بحر الصين
الجنوبي المناورات ستشمل ايضا هبوط مروحيه
عسكريه في جزيره فلبينيه تقع على مسافه
ثلاثه مئه كيلو متر من تايوان الامر الذي
اغضب بك والتي علقت بان هذه التدريبات يجب
الا تتدخل في نزاعات بحر الصين الجنوبي
ناهيك عن الحق الضرر بسياده الصين وحقوقها
ومصالحها الامنيه تحديدا
في خطوه قد تزيد من ارباك القطاع الصحي في
بريطانيا بدا الاف الاطباء الشباب اضرابا
عن العمل لمده اربعه ايام مطالبين باجور
افضل وسط ازمه التضخم وغلاء المعيشه التي
تعصف بالبلاد المدير العام للنظام الصحي
ببريطانيا وصف الاضراب بانه الاكثر تاثيرا
في تاريخ القطاع وسيسبب تاثيرا سلبيا
كبيرا مضيفا اكثر من 350 الف موعد طبيا قد
يؤجل وبالتالي ستكون الاولويه فقط للحالات
الطارئه حيث يمثل الاطباء الاطباء
المتدربون نحو نصف الاطباء في المستشفيات
البريطانيه
خلال بث مباشر عبر تطبيق انستجرام اقدم
موظفا في احد البنوك الامريكيه بولايه
كنتاكي على قتل خمسه من زملائه في العمل
واصاب تسع اخرين بعد اطلاق النار عليهم
الشرطه الامريكيه قالت ان الموظفه المهاجم
ماذو 23 عاما والذي كان مسلحا ببندقيه قتل
في مكان الحادث برصاصه دون ان يتضح ما اذا
كانت وفاته بسبب نيران الشرطه ام انه
انتحر وفيما لم يتبين حتى الان الاسباب
التي دفعته لتلك الفعل
[موسيقى]
قد يبدو عاديا لكثير من الناس بيع فيما
زاد في هونج كونج مقابل اكثر من 25 مليون
دولار القائمون على المزاد وصف الوعاء
الذي يبلغ قطره اقل من احد عشر سنتيمترا
بانه مهم لعده اسباب اوله ان الوعاء ينحدر
من مجموعه نادره من الخزفيات التي صنعتها
ورش الامبراطوريه الصينيه بالقرن الثامن
عشر وصنع في عهد الامبراطور يوم تشينغ
ويتزين الوعاء بطائري سنون الى جانب شجره
مشمش مزهره اضافه لشجره صفصاف كما يشمل
تصميمه مقتطفات من قصيده امبراطوريه
نبقى في الصين حيث اقتحمت مجموعه علي بابا
التجاريه عالم الذكاء الاصطناعي بعد
اطلاقها اليوم نموذجها للذكاء الاصطناعي
التوليدي لنسخه شبيهه لتلك المستخدمه في
روبوت الدردشه
بيانوا لشركه الصينيه قال ان تطبيق
الدردشه هذا سيكون باللغتين الصينيه
والانجليزيه وانها ستدمج قريبا في جميع
اعمال علي بابا حيث سيؤدي عددا من المهام
من بينها تحويل المحادثات في الاجتماعات
الى ملاحظات مكتوبه وكتابه رسائل البريد
البريد الالكتروني وصياغه مقترحات العمل
ايضا
[موسيقى]